i've been an iphone user ever since the
iphone 6 and now i own an iphone 13 pro
max which i love however samsung just
released their galaxy s22 ultra and i've
been playing around with it for over a
week now and i've gotta say that i'm
pretty impressed but at the same time
there are a couple of things that i'm
disappointed about this new design of
the s22 ultra basically beats out the
iphone because honestly i'm getting kind
of bored of this look in this design but
all in all i think samsung has created
the best flagship smartphone that
they've made in years especially in
terms of the design and camera quality
but i'm still a bit disappointed about a
few of the features like the display
brightness claims the lackluster speaker
quality and the upsetting gaming
performance and in terms of how it
compares to the iphone i think they're
just about neck and neck considering the
fact that the s22 ultra is more
expensive so i honestly wouldn't want to
switch to it especially since i really
love ios